well one effect of the pandemic and its
lockdowns has been a rise in drug use
worldwide including cocaine now for drug
cartels that's big business and it's had
ramifications for communities across
latin america
our next report takes us to colombia
where mexican drug cartels appear to be
playing a bigger role
these farmers used to harvest coca
plants three times a year but now they
have to double that as mexican drug
cartels look to cultivate not just
cocaine but their relationships with the
farmers who grow it the cartels send
representatives to pay farmers in
advance and push highly productive
streams
for the first time in many years coca
growers in the region have the cash
immediately and often up front
because the ability to move money from
the areas of kokuta to katatombo for
example is immense
the cartels are awash with money and
many farmers in the region need needed
which also makes them more willing to
comply with cartel's demands to boost
efficiency and it seems to be working
average annual use of cocaine cultivated
per hectare has risen good news for the
cartels but more pressure on the
farmers whoever has control of the
cultivation areas and laboratories and
can meet demand can also maintain
relations with the mexican cartels
some farmers are experimenting with new
seeds these varieties are especially
fruitful and a product of cartel funded
cultivation and it doesn't stop there
the cartels are also funding labs and
warehouses to coordinate shipments and
even investing in docks with access to
pacific ocean
drug trafficking has increased because
the government has given up
and it's not just now it has been
happening for years
trafficking has deep roots here because
the government has been permissive the
state has been permissive with poor
families
activists say gangs and cartels are
profiting off of the poverty fewer
opportunities and lack of state presence
for the farmers it's a source of much
needed income and they have very little
choice but to accept
elizabeth dickinson is a senior analyst
for the international crisis group she
joins me now from bogota elizabeth help
us to understand this a little bit
better why are mexican cartels choosing
this moment right now to really up their
involvement in colombia
i think it's a simple question of supply
and demand the demand for a drug has
generally increased since the pandemic
and the mexican cartels are well
positioned to move that product from
colombia which is one of the largest
suppliers of cocaine unfortunately
to the most
in demand markets now i think that we
need to make a clear distinction here
although the mexican cartels are very
important in terms of setting the price
and being the main primary buyer for
this product on the ground in colombia
their role remains extremely limited and
i would say in many cases really only a
commercial relationship rather than any
sort of innate relationship with the the
dynamics of armed groups and conflict
within colombia
at the same time it sounds like drug
growers coca growers in colombia are
planting less acreage and yet they're
reaping higher yields and they're being
paid in some cases with weapons what
does this mean for overall stability in
these regions
it's a very challenging dynamic um
there have been advances in the
efficiency of the production of coca in
recent years which means that you can
produce more cocaine per hectare of coca
grown it but really again um i think the
price issue has been one of the primary
reasons that the production has
increased so significantly and the price
being paid here has risen in recent
months and over the past several years
and that really incentivizes in
armed and criminal groups it to go into
these communities that have
traditionally grown coca and including
into new areas that we've seen expand
into coca since the signing of the 2016
peace agreement here um and really in
some cases coerce farmers to grow this
product and we have to also be clear
that what farmers themselves are earning
from a growing coca is really a
subsistence living so the the benefits
sort of the gains of this product are
all higher up the food chain in terms of
armed and criminal groups that gives
them enormous power in the countryside
and they have exercised it
ruthlessly in terms of controlling
territory and populations and it shows
no sign of stopping in in the coming
months unfortunately
well the government of colombia
meanwhile targeting coca farmers in many
cases by eradicating their crops is this
the right way to go about it is that
fair on farmers and if not what should
be done to put a dent in the supply of
cocaine what the current approach does
is essentially puts the entire cost of
what's happening here on poor farmers
who are in many cases violently obliged
to cultivate coca so i think it is
absolutely the wrong approach
in fact what's needed is to look again
higher up the food chain at where the
profits really are looking at
trafficking looking at really tackling
financial profits abroad money that's
being moved for example into the united
states where it's often quite
untouchable
and instead the current approach what it
has essentially done is alienated these
poor and farmers in the countryside who
are find themselves between a rock and a
hard place they're being um forcibly
obliged to to cultivate in many cases
they have no alternative lifestyle that
would be able to provide them a
subsistence income and at the same time
they're being persecuted both by armed
groups and by the government
in this impossible situation this does
very little additionally to affect the
actual production of cocaine and there's
been a significant amount of research
about the levels of replanting so when
eradication happens at the moment and
we've been told by the armed forces here
in colombia that replanting rates can be
up to 85 to 90 percent which is to say
that for every hectare or every 100
hectares you eradicate you're really
only eradicating 10 or 15. an enormous
investment in money it with a very
confrontational approach towards the
community with very little payoff
all right so not only unfair but
ineffective in many many ways elizabeth
dickinson with the international crisis
group in bogota thank you so much